King you want to show it
[Music]
can you see oh boy yeah yeah okay you
can play it
when I talk about those uh men's Peak
sexual market value it's right around 36
37 38 years old right there and the
reason for that is because women have
different criteria for what they find
arousing and attractive so when a guy is
right around 35 36 37 that's the years
and which he has the most potential to
have what makes him the most attractive
to women that's that's how I judge that
that's how I I put that out there now
the thing is is that it takes longer for
men to get there it takes longer for men
to mature into that yes it does and it's
not because it's not because
[Music]
it's because it takes longer because men
must be common women just all I was just
gonna say you used that quote the other
day I was like oh what the hell does
that mean well because women women are
and men must be called what does that
mean okay so because like Adam even said
like I was crazy partying when I was
younger and I I feel like I've even
dated guys now who are like no I like
your age that you're older I can't deal
with a 21 year old girl they're trying
to work you no they're not no no she
does have a point like
there are 21 22 23 year olds running
around where it's like yeah they're hot
no doubt yeah but a lot of guys don't
want to I'm not trying to ask about how
you're you know how was class today baby
like I need someone who at least has
some substance of what's going on so for
me 25 to like 30 scores but once again
were you as were you in your most Peak
potential when you were in your 20s or
when you hit 30 or 40. now how much
money do you have for a guy
35 to basically now I feel like I'm in
Prime you have everyone's on their own
Journey so like yeah certain people can
hit numbers earlier or for me personally
like I thought for sure I was gonna be
married and have a family but now I'm so
grateful that I didn't and have these
other projects and passions that I've
established on my own so and on this
note you're from Miami South Beach no
where are you from no I'm originally
Southern California okay Miami
something I'm from up North I'm from
Pennsylvania the north is so different
every place is different yeah when I
left here people said why would you
leave Miami and my answer it was
difficult to describe but I said my soul
was dying
because I felt that way in L.A oh my God
yes you're just you're evaluated so
critically and and then too it's kind of
fun when you like reach the top of
everyone's standards and you're like
okay [__] you bye it's just it's not
interesting that's what I realized when
I when I went back I saw it was a
magazine ad for a yoga and I was like oh
my God that's my body I was perfect but
it's never enough because there's a
million other people and it's never
enough and so where I am right now I'm
kind of getting hit as if I am supposed
to take a partner
I don't want it I have so much
calm I have like I have such a nice life
and I didn't have that nice life when
all of this headache was going on
when's your like birthday
like what's your astrology sign oh cool
I'm so happy you asked yeah it's uh I'm
December 29th so you're a Capricorn as
well I'm a Capricorn
we are like very
loyal hard workers Rebecca you
fascinated here's my question for you
yes how many of your best friends best
friends are married with kids
foreign
I don't have a lot of best friends but I
know everybody who all your friends from
high school college graduate school when
I went back up there if there's a
hundred of them how many of them are
married with kids from graduate school
they're mostly from other countries in
general she doesn't compare herself
that's not my point but it's not a
comparison
number no I see them and they've they've
grown and they have other lives and
they've they have husbands and this just
isn't my life what percentage I think a
lot of them do so 90 plus percent I
guess okay well I'm just saying all my
best friends and I have dozens and I
grew up in Miami all my friends
like five percent I'm still hanging with
we're going out like five percent
meaning the other 95 are married with
kids so you're the anomaly this is all
I'm trying to say is that you're
successful beautiful and I don't need no
man I got my own thing because because
you're it's not it I don't need no man
it's I have a very happy peaceful life I
love what I do I get better at what I do
every day and if there's somebody who
can enhance my happiness I'm very happy
your career is your baby I would say
career it's more of a call her passion
absolutely
I
agree with what you were saying just
because a lot of my friends are mostly
in couples and
I do think about like okay they're gonna
have babies soon and I like I don't want
to be the single friend forever you
won't be a Victoria you're going to be
great thank you
uh what did you guys think of that clip
sheesh
I wouldn't say she's I think what a guy
was saying like about men becoming like
I can relate to that based on what I was
saying before but oh yes the clothes and
the hair and that's me becoming I had to
go through that in order to be who I am
now
um
so I can relate to that
I think it was I think what did you
think of the women in the clip
I feel like the woman the older woman if
I can say that um
she seemed she reminded me of um the
other lady but um she's a little bit
scattered like he's asking direct
questions and she can't give an answer
and she's saying that her career isn't a
career so call him but if that's what
you do in
then that's what you do it's your career
but then I don't know it it just seems
like she wasn't
really sure of herself she I feel like
she's happy in what she's doing but like
she said when she was when she thought
she looked perfect she wanted more but I
still feel like she she came across like
to me that she still wanted more anyway
even though she might not be outwardly
saying that
I think she was delusional she's just
fooling herself those women it's like
they're just so resigned because she
said my life is so peaceful now like
it's not possible to have a peaceful
life with a man so I think women like
that are just so resigned that it can't
be possible why why do you think she's
like that
um programming I think people uh
look I live in my own bubble because I
don't like being too
um too much exposed to all this
information
people are just told how they should
think I think
um I I had um two friends they're older
than me and um one of them was a guy and
one of them was a lady who
um so the guy was saying
um I don't have time I'm my business is
my baby and after after a while that
we've been hanging out and I realized
actually he loves to have a partner or a
wife but he's got so many attitudes that
I don't think he can keep anyone and I
think sometimes they know that they have
so many
um I don't know if there's the right way
to say it they have so many issues that
they can't
hold on to a relationship and they have
so many I don't want to call it failure
but they had so many unsuccessful
relationships that when it comes to the
public they decide to say oh I'm I'm my
business is my baby I'm very happy but
generally they're not really happy they
just feel like it's going to be it's a
cope yeah yeah I
agreement it's the men or the women this
one the one it's a guy do you do you see
that women
um older single women are generally
happy being older and single no no no no
I don't mind I mean I don't know
I think because I have a daughter so I'm
kind of like I think if I I didn't have
a daughter I probably will be like
desperate to have a relationship and get
married and I definitely would say that
but you are in a relationship so you're
not single so how would you know how no
that's why I I'm kind of like thinking
that's why it's difficult Amanda you're
right because when you you're in a you
know
um
and you felt lonely like and you've got
your daughter and she's living her own
life she's 16 like you said right now
yeah so it's difficult for me to you're
right to making you know the state do
you think if you didn't have a daughter
that you would be lonely
no
do you think you'd be perfectly
fulfilled no I wanted to be in
relationships no I'm saying like if you
didn't have a relationship or a daughter
do you think you would be lonely
no not now
I feel quite fulfilled with my uh
partner and my no but I'm saying sorry
maybe I don't get I'm saying if you
didn't have a partner like if you have
no partner and no daughter
[Music]
no partner no daughter yeah
I would do you know any women in that
position especially because all my
friends they're all like married having
two three kids and literally all of them
are married and having kids probably I
would feel lonely yeah
were there any things you did to um you
said you're a trainer have you always
been in shape or did you like lose
weight
I I always been in shape but obviously
when I got pregnant like I you know
overweight and then I had a positive
depression of the my daughter so I put
on
25 kilos and I had to lose it it took me
about eight months so and then since
then I've been trying to be in in shape
yeah and it's very important to me to be
honest so I don't know if it's anything
to do because I'm a personal trainer
even in my family my mom my sister
they're all like you know they're not
personal trainer but they are all very
sporty and very fit
so um yeah what did you guys think of
the clip
or I don't think you said anything I
mean yeah women got a clock
so basically when the younger they have
to settle down that's what I think
you say that again when they're young
younger they have to settle down because
the older they get the more difficult is
it so he's smarter at what age do you
think dating is damn near impossible for
women maybe 40 35 40. 35 it's gonna be
difficult possible but difficult you
know yeah and what would you suggest to
women that want to compete at that age
like what what could they do
but it's not smart yeah yeah never
imagine like what like what what advice
would you give them if they're they're
in that situation what do they have to
keep trying keep trying but it's
difficult you know yeah what about you
yeah I was just gonna say in that to
that um see that with with
the delusion quite frankly you know it's
almost like this they feel they need to
be this um
this martyr and the thing they all sing
from that same sheet you know him sheet
of like um you know I'm happy as I am
and there's I just get this energy or
this Aura of like them really trying to
convince them the person but really
themselves they're trying to convince
you know but they're not they're not and
that's why they can't answer the
questions straight yeah a simple
question wouldn't it like honestly
it would be so much more honest if they
just said you know I'm not happy and I
fail that relationship that I don't know
how to fix it like what did that mean I
feel comfortable saying that like I
failed that I didn't do whatever I
needed to do to make sure that that
would be the refreshing tape but but it
is so like it is so one can only be
using this word empowering because of
how people use it
in that way and I think just taking
personal responsibility otherwise
everything else is literally victimhood
you either take 100 responsibility for
the way your life is and the way it is
and or you are a victim of your
circumstances that is literally how I
see life that's true and in that space
there isn't really any upset there is
just okay so what am I gonna do about it
now I'm all about action results so what
am I going to do about it now yes yes
but then again that is a that's more of
a masculine thing here we go but it's
it's good though it's good yeah you can
balance it and you have this mindset and
this way of thinking but not bring it
into a relationship with a man and and
yeah
so it takes a man and a woman to make a
man or a woman so yes it's not
necessarily A Bad Thing King I sent you
one more video to react to oh
when you have a second I still get the
feeling it's going to be a fresher
feeling no no not fresh
no I just feel like
um
if people were more honest now then
because this is a type of media so
people who are more honest with
themselves on these platforms people in
society would be more honest with
themselves why do you think people are
not
because they know that it's going out to
all these to however many people I think
I think it makes them look bad yes
to look bad and nobody like nobody wants
to admit that like that they look bad
yeah that they're bad at something and
that is what keeps you looking back yeah
because that's a that's the thing like a
lot of people think I go in on women but
it's like how are we supposed to get
better if we don't admit there's a
problem yeah and even the stuff you're
talking about like I relate to it a lot
being an athlete like you grow up as a
tomboy you don't learn a lot of the
girly stuff
like it's interesting that you grew up
with um your your mom because I found a
lot of tomboys grew up like their
Daddy's Girls well I was at Daddy's girl
I mean he was I was his firstborn so he
was like a football boots I've noticed
that too it's a lot of first-born girls
because that's me I'm like the firstborn
girl so it's like you're kind of a
daddy's girl so they kind of raise us to
be boys a little bit I don't know about
you but you know that's how yeah as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible